the Joe Rogan experience I was gonna
take though I will get totally [ __ ]
nude and Pepsi
hey wait say that Tim you're gonna see
the obvious and smash up up the OB lady
obviously in Spanish obeah OBO what are
you doing
or you'll take don't take a piss don't
don't put your don't piss on the ground
you can put your pants on some definite
not getting on the scale underwear on
there why are you scared of scales Bert
because Joe it's not like this hasn't
defined the last four years of my life
online but you're very well right now
you look great yeah thanks I'd rather
people think I look like I know a nice
target weight is 175 to 180 mmm okay
target weight that's like loose skin
yeah that's weird remember a six-pack
yeah all right had a full six-pack look
at that he's got a little bit of a
six-pack there you skinny no he's got
abs it's not just any skinny
what do you got zero it's on carpet or a
big 180 we call six 180 point six mm-hmm
and that is with socks on yeah it's the
carpet I don't trust carpet on these
scales okay man you don't have to get on
it that's after two weeks in Colombia
with nothing but fried food I'm okay
with that
rolling today for lunch but DITA paisa
one thing that I did realize when you
did sober October when the we did the
fitness challenge is that if you just
went whole hog you were crazy
you'd be a beast I ate nearly a whole
hog today no but I mean if you like
worked out really hard you'd have a good
body here's the thing that I learned in
server October and and then Tom kept
having to say this to me over and over
again is that what makes re re is not
going for hog like like if you go for
hog it'sit's not re you get a turns in
like and the same with me like what I
get obsessed with weight and it it
starts to beat ya thing that defines you
is the thing that defines you take this
slow is no it's not even that crazy it's
true and you'll know it's true is I'm
gonna wait till the fourth quarter
really turn
and then the fourth quarter you'll do it
insane there's no way you're gonna be
like I'm a study for this [ __ ] yeah
you're not gonna prepare things when you
say things like times you said split
will you think when you got down you
knew you didn't what do you think
thematically all of a sudden you would
get really flexible what's your
confidence he goes in with it we're
thinking like I've never gonna split my
life I know they're hard to do and I
can't you do it even though I know he's
a bullshitter every part of me it was
like wow Burke into a split nothing he
ran four miles in his life and then he
[ __ ] it did a marathon the next five or
six on the treadmill which is like one
in real life that is true yeah I think
I'm a marathon you will say I can do
that to anything okay I'll say I can do
that to anything you're definitely get
on it but don't you feel that way what
are you do anything no yeah yeah but you
can do anything
no but do you think it's great discourse
this is actually what defines the to it
you'll keep going the same the same fire
burns for both of us right so what do
you think of like you can do anything
right you go no I can't I need to work
hard to have another stroke no no no you
go harder yeah you go I'm gonna I'm
gonna I can't shoot a bow and arrow a
perfect shot I want to learn that I want
to bust my ass wanna do that I'm the
opposite way where I go just give me a
shot let me try this right here Lister
you can surf that is your guy's
personality differences very different
I'm very objective about what I can and
can't do I'm good at things you have to
you have to really look at what you're
good and not good at and then work
really hard at getting good at things
otherwise you're just bullshitting
yourself and or that gets you hurt if
you're a fighter
look at you really hurt yeah but that's
it's it's it actually is really
interesting to think about your
background is what informs that
you just expressed and his experience is
that saying that sometimes works out
like that's why he keeps studying
college most undiscovered me all of a
sudden I got a career he's the guy who
will say but it worked you will be
somebody's will smith discovers me
managing what the [ __ ] yeah say I want
to run a marathon I do it and then I go
and then I said me should heard me the
day I ran the marathon I was like I
think I can actually do anything
wait didn't you say something did you
say something about kicking field goals
35-yard easily with no worry thank you
Scott Norwood mister 35 yarder and they
lined up and then I said everybody
washed in a stadium it's kind of like
trying to 35 yarder and people did it
people didn't do it I could easily
[Applause]